this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
and i want to be really clear about that
rich versace is the best leader i've
ever been around breaking this hour
hearing from the raiders for the first
time since the team parted ways with
former coach john gruden good afternoon
thanks so much for joining us i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casadas
let's get right to our team coverage
this afternoon john treach standing by
here in studio but first organa is live
outside allegion where the raiders
general manager spoke earlier today orca
well christian raiders general manager
mike mayok says there has been a lot
going on behind the scenes with the
raiders organization the past several
days at today's press conference he
talked very little about gruden directly
but he shed light on how the team is
feeling
john gruden has stepped down as raiders
head coach after several emails
resurfaced showing him using homophobic
misogynistic and racist comments raiders
general manager mike mayok says it's
been a tough week for everyone including
raiders owner mark davis who mayok says
has been the primary person dealing with
the emails the players are also
wrestling with a wide range of emotions
raiders defensive lineman carl nasib the
league's only active openly gay player
requested a personal day to process
everything there was also a team meeting
this morning to talk about resources for
the players and here's what mayok said
about gruden resigning i am sad and to
be honest with you i'm sad for the whole
gruden family
okay not just john
but at the end of the day we're all
accountable for our actions and
that's how we have to look at it there
was also no definitive answer to why
gruden still coached sunday's game if
davis had the emails on friday
mayak says he's now trying to shift the
attention back to football so his focus
right now is on sunday's game against
denver but for now we're going to toss
it back to the studio where john treach
has more on the new leader of the silver
in black john
thank you arco the highest profile
sports figure in las vegas resigned from
his job and in a cloud of shame but as
the haze of hysteria clears one man has
been promoted to the pinnacle of his
profession rich basatia is now the head
coach of the raiders a responsibility
only 20 men in history can understand it
only took 39 years of coaching but
versace has stepped to the podium as a
head coach the 61 year old new yorker
got his nfl break on john gruden's tampa
bay staff he has been a special teams
coordinator for the past two decades
with the chargers cowboys bucks and
raiders he's respected as a grinder and
an advocate for his players today the
behind the scenes technician takes on
the biggest spotlight of his life
this is certainly an exciting moment no
one wants to be a head coach in this
particular situation no one wants to be
put
in front of this uh under these
particular circumstances but it's a um
incredible opportunity certainly not
only for me but all the other coaches
that are here to um
you know see we can what we can do with
this adversity see what we can do with
this challenge see we can do with the
next day and same thing for our players
at practice this morning the man with
the new power and title was not putting
on a show for the media instead he was
on the far practice field working with
the kicker sweating encouraging leading
by example christian